I've been thinking
I can't run this club forever
I built discs for nothing
this is my family
you want me kid
[Music]
from the beginning
yes please
it was a golden age bike riders and I
never felt so at a place in all my life
that's when I saw him for the first time
I took my breath away
[Music]
later in Maryland
I thought I could change him you know
not to be different but to be
I don't know like he's Wild
hey
I told you to take that jacket off
you'd have to kill
what about the bar
Ney dollars
the club got real big real fast they
started running drugs gambling
prostitution I said I want this club is
now
need to quit riding
I can't have them if he wants to ride a
bike
you ride a bike
just think it over you know
foreign